WITH EDMONTON, THE DOWNSLILI LI
FOUND IT.
HERE'S A PASS,KEITH, KEPTSAVE,
THE
BACKHAND SIDE.
EXCELLENT ENTRY BY LINDHO
SKATING AWAY.
A  THROUGH
LOOKING TO SCORE,
AND SHUTTING THE BACK
TOGETHER IT'S ALMOST IN
THE NET!
JUST A GREAT JOB.
IT WAS A QUICK LITTLE PASS THAT
KIND OF FUMBLES TO GO ON THE POR
PLAY.
BACKLUND OVER TO MANGIAPANE!
THE FLAMES CAPITALIZE ON THE OF
THE SHOULDER ON THE SHORTGAME.
>> Harnarayan: HERE'S A CHANCE
FOR JOHNNY GAUDREAU, SKATING
TOWARDS T T SKATING AWAY WITH I.
PLAYS THEUT OF THE LINEUP FOR
THE EDMONTON OILERS RIGHT
[ Horn ]
IT'S ANOTHER POWER PLAY
GET THAT SHOT THROUGH, AND
AGAIN, IT'S PULJUJARVI IN FRONT.
LOOK AT THAT ANGLE. THE BOARDS.
GUDBRANSON AND GAUDREAU TO
TKACHUKIPPED
OVER TO LUCIC.
LUCIC WAITS, SHOOTS, AND
KOSKINEN, THE BIG STOP, BAC
PERLINI!AFTERWARDS,
HANIFIN THE SHOT, AND IT'S A TIE
GAME ONCE AGAIN WITH A SHOT FROM
THE POINT.
STICK THROUGH, BUT KOSKINEN  OV
JOHNNY GAUDREAU, THEY HAVE SOME
ROOM.
GAUDREAU A PASS
BENSON, OVER TO
BIG STOP AGAIN FROM MIKKO
KOSKINEN!
ONE-GOAL LEAD.
WHAT A IT'S 5-3 FOR THE
EDMONTON OILERS.